un nobel para entender el cambio
climático el científico estadounidense
japonés y okur humana ve klaus
hasselmann de alemania y giorgio parís
italia ganaron este martes el premio
nobel de física por ayudar a la
comprensión de sistemas físicos tan
complejos como nuestro clima
mi contribución podría considerarse como
la dirección para al menos intentar
comprender cuál es nuestro problema
en los últimos 20 años fenómenos
climáticos intensos como las
inundaciones se incrementaron
dramáticamente unos fenómenos agravados
por el calentamiento de 1,5 grados de
temperatura del planeta que implica más
de cielos subidas del nivel del mar y
más olas de calor
eventos que están al frente de las
preocupaciones de los jóvenes
cuando los jóvenes hacen un poco de
presión al respecto también puede tener
un efecto me alegra mucho que lo hagas
el trabajo del italiano parisi hizo
posible que se entiendan mejor los
fenómenos aleatorios
creo que el premio es importante no sólo
para mí sino también para los otros dos
[Música]
porque el cambio climático es una gran
amenaza para la humanidad y es
extremadamente importante que el
gobierno actúe con determinación lo más
rápido posible
para la academia sueca el trabajo de los
científicos es fundamental porque
vincula la actividad humana al
calentamiento global